[Applause]
it was the announcement that chile had
been waiting for impatiently especially
the name of the next finance minister
we have the challenge to recover our
economy without reproducing structural
inequalities in other words sustainable
growth with a fair distribution of
wealth
the markets reacted positively to the
choice of central bank president mario
marcel who could not attend because of a
suspected covet infection
marcel is a widely respected technocrat
who shares president-elect gabriel
morich's goals for greater social
justice
this sends an important signal of
commitment to economic growth with
responsibility but also with a social
purpose to generate a better quality of
life in chile
the new cabinet is made up of
independents members of boric's new left
coalition three socialists and three
communist party nominees in all ten men
and fourteen women including isia
the former president of the medical
guild will become chile's first female
interior minister
another highlight the new defense
minister will be the granddaughter of
former president salvador allende who
was overthrown by the military in
nineteen seventy three
the bondage cabinet will be the second
youngest in chile in history
interestingly a great many of the
ministers in key positions were educated
in the united states and especially in
the uk
and that is clearly a message to those
who were concerned that inexperience in
the new government would be the rule
rather than the exception
idina caramanos a feminist to his
bodhich's partner has agreed to act as
first lady
but it's the cabinet along with bodhich
himself who face the greatest
challenges you must know that everyone
is waiting for us to make chile a more
kind place to live where dignity becomes
the norm so that we can restore
confidence in government our
institutions and
it's a politics cabinet that will
accompany the 35 year old new left
leader a former student activist and
congressman who in march will become one
of the world's youngest presidents
lucia newman al jazeera santiago